[Music]
we're doing a tabata here today that we
are um
how are you buddy i'm good man good i
think we're uh
so we actually had another um
podcast interview with a guy lined up
and unfortunately the uh the quality of
it was not so good so any future guest
out there we prefer you don't use a cell
phone
yeah it just doesn't come through very
well just just doesn't with this
especially in the mountains especially
in the mountains yeah it was uh good
stories great great conversation uh just
the quality of the uh the audio the
video was just not up to the cocktails
and cocktail standards so it's going to
be the two of us sitting here looking at
each other and we did we had some other
interviews we could have run through but
we've kind of got our little format laid
out what we're going to do yeah well we
the thing that we usually do is we talk
about all this stuff about policing and
crime and stuff off the air we're kind
of going to do that on the air today
exactly there's a lot to cover there's a
lot to cover we're going to have our
normal conversations that we have in the
background and then we're going to
answer some questions that people ask us
a lot
like people are calling in and i'm not
aware of this yeah they can't they call
that okay
yeah i won't give them your number
unless you want me to it's on several
bathroom walls okay in here uh down
sound pony for sure that
there's a lot of things on the walls in
sound pony lots and lots of things yeah
anybody that ever makes a trip into
tulsa oklahoma or if you live in tulsa
for whatever reason you have never been
there sound pony is a must
uh
bar
it is a fixture it is it i mean it
really is and a good friend of mine john
zito who you've gotten to know as well
he was executive producer live pd he and
his lovely wife
came into tulsa to hang out with us for
a weekend and
john is a lifelong
literally manhattan guy right born and
raised in manhattan lives in the lower
east side italian guy from the city his
entire life is new york and when he came
here to tulsa first time here
we took him to sound pony as one of the
many places and he was in in kane's
ballroom and he was in absolute heaven
just couldn't believe tulsa oklahoma had
bars like that that didn't you know his
exact words were just like a dive bar in
in new york oh it's a it's a fixture man
and tulsa tufts coming up in july so
it's going to and surprisingly that bar
the two owners of that bar
great philanthropists do lots of great
things they do a thing called
bike club where they uh get kids in in
elementary schools
to kind of join this group
and once they've joined this group and
completed it throughout the semester at
the end of the semester they give a free
bike wow nice
getting kids on bikes like when we were
kids that was your freedom machine yeah
tulsa tough uh again just a little tulsa
history here it is a bike race
um you know here in tulsa howard's
heavily involved in the viking community
and tulsa i pretended there for a little
bit i said i was fat yeah
i'm a heavily i'm a heavy cycler that's
what you did in the clydesdale division
yeah absolutely but no it it's a race
that's here in tulsa and it literally
has
it's a bike a road race with some of the
best racers in the country that come
here to participate
and uh it is basically tulsa's mardi
gras also because there is what is known
as crybaby hill here
again
research it find it it's worth the
travel in because it legitly is like
mardi gras it is a leave your kids at
home yeah kids aren't allowed on the
hill you don't want your kids out there
i promise but it is a good time kids are
definitely not allowed on the hill you
guys you know what like sorry to cut you
know it is loud out there
everything else
that is true this is true alcohol oh
lots of it and we got a podcast right
here that involves it we do hey well we
get questions every once in a while
well i've got a question for you okay um
we have a lot of bourbon between us that
is true right you know people talk about
their body count and that kind of stuff
yep we will talk about bourbon body
counts okay so uh what's your body count
how many bottles are you up to now man i
counted it probably
maybe two or three months ago and i
think it was like 238 and that's
different that's not duplicates that's
238 different
varietals yeah but different bottles um
so there's these i'm sorry does that
include no actually it did not count
anything that we have here in the studio
so
some of these that we have here in the
studio actually probably are duplicates
that i have at the house that you know
yeah i can tell you this i sure as hell
don't have a shiva's regal at the house
no that was awful we didn't even uh
bless charles brandt's heart we didn't
even get to have him out no yeah that
well yeah there's a couple here like
that blatant bow i don't have another
one of those at the house the redwood
empire i don't have in i'll don't i'll
leave it here you don't have to have
that how about yourself what are you up
to um i'm sh i'm north of 400. yeah but
and what do you think jason's at jason's
not here with us today man it's early
yeah honestly jason i'm gonna guess he's
probably in the
i don't know north of 500 yeah yeah over
500 and and
jason has a lot of
he got a lot of good stuff i'll say
excuse my language a lot of big dick
bottles yeah i mean he does he's got a
lot of them that are
very old he's been in the game before
well long before me but definitely he
got in after me but he just went crazy
he did and that's that's jason man he
goes all in yeah i mean if he likes them
he goes for it what let me what's your
most prized bottle i i guess whether it
be because of the taste
the sentimental value that somebody gave
to you or
you know a monetary value man it's it's
the cocktails bottles
good answer those are the bottles i mean
who else has got one that says cocktails
and cocktails that's right that's right
you guys can still buy some of those at
park hill lake or if you're interested
there are and mary's liquor and
tahlequah yeah there's some as well that
one's uh and then of course i don't know
if nashville barrel company has it
they're down to the last few bottles
okay but um as far rarest bottle i have
is i have a suicide bottle which um
they took
knob creek 25 bottles of that different
barrel
picks from different stores mixed it
together and made a knob creek suicide
so there's only 25 of those around 25
bottles or 25 barrels 25 bottles there's
only 25 of those in the world wow i
don't know if it tastes good or anything
it probably doesn't but i haven't opened
it because it's that one what's your
rarest bottle um my rarest bottle i
actually just got this week
um so when the tornadoes hit kentucky
last year um obviously that's where
you know it's bourbon bourbon country
all the distilleries and whatnot are
but a lot of them places like buffalo
trace put out like this huge collection
that had you know all the papi's all the
different things and it was a fundraiser
basically they were raising money for
tornado relief
and um my kind or my kinds our good
friend out at national barrel company um
he and a lot of the big names in the
bourbon industry big names big names
like
godfathers yeah um they went in and
bought a barrel from four roses which is
actually the oldest barrel
burl the oldest barrel for four roses
has ever put out 19 years four months
um and i think it produced like 160
bottles roughly
and uh i end up buying one of them well
i will tell you that that is a very rare
bottle and the amount of money they
raised to buy that barrel was just
through the roof yeah they also had the
opportunity to pick a i think a 20-year
21-year too and they said that was just
too old they said it was too okay yeah
so they uh
i mean i think that barrel went for
close to three hundred thousand if i
remember correctly is what they bought
it for something like that yes i mean it
was some it was a huge number but again
it was for charity exactly and so
um you know i bought a bottle it wasn't
cheap but it's a unique bottle and it
was for such a good cause that that i
went in and bought one um kind of other
than that my other one you know just
like you said the cocktails cocktails
are of course so meaningful both you
know because of the podcast our
friendship that we did this with you
know us and our other friends when we
pick bottles
the experience of going through and
picking those creating labels
um i've got myself a mickers 20. that's
a that's a that's a big bottle that's a
big bottle i'm not going to open that
one until i get a hole in one in golf
that's what i've set for myself i will
crack off
yeah it's got to be legal
and then um you know you guys i mean
you've given me some great bottles um
you know my retirement and you know some
of that type of stuff so there's
definitely bottles that have sentimental
value out there yeah but you got to
drink them you absolutely know this i
gave you a lot of shit about not
drinking whiskey in the beginning you
would just look at them and stare at
them like they're pretty you like they
were the ring from
the hobbit oh my precious i can't open
you i i did have that for a while so i
didn't know you can have dusty's develop
in your own living room yeah it happens
pretty quickly okay so out of those what
is what what's your favorite
and we get asked this what's your
favorite because we you got north of 200
bottles yeah um you know one of the ones
i really really like there's an old elk
uh
sour mash batch number one and i think
that's a fantastic is that what you
actually drinking legit
i didn't know that's what you were
drinking and i'm not would that be this
one that would be it i love that um and
honestly i love weller foolproof
yeah that is such a to me just an easy
easy bottle and then there's the uh
something i started out on which anybody
that comes over that doesn't drink i try
to introduce them to is the old blue
label uh basil hayden's um was it the
caribbean
rum dude that's not bourbon not to say
it's not rum i mean it's like 80 proof i
mean it's not sure but it's if you want
exactly if you want something that just
tastes good tastes sweet that's a good
good bottle
um it's not a go-to it's something now
that when people come over and have
never had bourbon you try to introduce
them yeah it's something that's easily
likable because it's super sweet it's
this one right here yeah that's the one
you're talking about that would be it uh
and it goes down too smooth and even at
80 when you drink a half a bottle of it
you will have a hangover it will hurt
you i have done that once or twice all
right how about yourself and then we're
gonna jump into some police topics okay
um
i'm a big weeded bourbon fan so people
will say what do you mean we do bourbon
well it's most bourbon's made with
quite a bit of corn quite a bit of rye
the weed of bourbons have a softer taste
because they have more wheat in them so
i'm a big fan of the weller products i
mean i think one of my favorites
probably
hands down like to drink all the time
it's like well or 12. i mean that is i
mean it used to be pretty easy to get
but now it's ridiculous to get
um as far as
types
it would be the weeded but i also like
those uh barrel proofs i like those ones
to kind of grab your tongue
as a drink more those are the ones that
i'm finding myself drawn to i really no
and speaking
listen we have no connection to old elk
just something a product we like there i
just saw they're putting out a double
wheat yeah
like last week they made an announcement
on that and i agree i love those high
proof um
that uh jack daniels coy hill which i'm
not a big jd fan man it's like a hundred
and something else
i have no clue i don't know if it's a
person or i don't know no no i think i
don't know is it a place i don't shit i
don't know that's what i mean anybody
out there knows let us know because we
have no damn idea
all right into um we do have to talk law
enforcement stuff so not everybody
that's listening is into bourbon so i
got a question for you okay um there's a
lot of topics to come out about fitness
with police yes yep and you've always
said the reason you work out is um
that you want to
reduce the amount of violence that
happens absolutely uh if if you're big
and strong people are less tender have
less tendency to mess with you right man
you know not necessarily big and strong
and i'll say this there are bad guys on
the street that if you are the big
athletic guy in the group you're the one
they're going to talk the shit to you
know if it's a small um a small frame
guy
you know a small female or something
like that
you know for a lot of these guys on the
street it's all about dominant male
that's what they know in the gang world
or get you know bad guys and so it's
like man what are they really proven if
they're trying to go after the smallest
person in the group so um
it's more to me about having
the words command presence so if you
look good in your uniform you keep your
shoes clean you know you don't have a
giant belly hanging over your gun belt
your gun belt's not all beaten up and
ratty looking you you know you're
replacing stuff as it starts to look bad
your uniform isn't doesn't look like
shit things like that that saves you
a lot i think dealing with people on the
street because they know hey this person
comes to work squared away right this
person's taking this job seriously
things like that now don't get me wrong
i mean i've you know been in fights and
chases and stuff like that with guys
despite trying to you know hold my
appearance up
but i think that goes a long way and
i can't speak for every police
department i know
you know every department i'm fairly
confident has what's called a use of
force continuum and it basically
is going to be in your manual your
policy and procedures and it talks about
the different various levels of force
the the bottom force is command presence
just you know i don't believe it's force
but that's just in there you just set
the tone in the literature it's like
that's the whole point you're there and
then it's usually like a verbal command
hey you know turn around right you know
and then it goes from there depending on
the suspect's actions is it you know
a dog bite a taser an impact weapon
which can be a fist or a you know
hickory baton all the way up to deadly
force being you know you're running
someone over the car you're shooting
them with a gun right
so yeah this leads me to the fact that
texas has been in the news a lot for
lots of things lately but one of the
things they just passed was they um and
they're getting a lot of flack for it
is that there is a
minimum or maximum waist size that you
can have to be a police officer on in
the texas state police correct it's
department public safety it's basically
like their troopers got you uh-huh uh
yeah so they uh it's something that the
administration uh i guess for a little
while has been has had or wanted and
they couldn't enforce it during the
coveted time
and just now it's gone back through so i
think there's roughly about 4 000 uh dps
and you know troopers down there in the
state of texas and i saw the numbers and
it was just a little over 200 it's like
213 or something like that that failed
um the the measurement test so what is
the measurement well it's literally the
waste they are measuring the waste and i
think it's any male that has a waist
over 40 inches and any female over 35
and that's considered a failure and then
they have another option
to do like either a running rowing bench
press some some type of testing to see
if they still pass and i think out of
that 213 that were considered
you know out of shape by the measurement
i think there's literally like only like
two or three that failed the test
um and so again going back to what i was
saying the command presence yes i
believe in it
however i don't think um you know
strictly somebody's waist size is a
measurement of their ability to be a cop
or their fitness level because listen uh
you know vic rigolato for instance here
in tulsa our sheriff
um guy played college football he was a
boxer for a little while he's run a
marathon and vic's a bigger guy now i
don't know what his waist size is but i
can tell you he can chase a bad guy down
and you know the bad guy chooses to
fight
victor will fight vic will fight you
know and so
the measurement i don't think that
should be the sole uh basis on the
fitness level of a person obviously it
does go hand in hand you know if you're
ob so you're overweight um but you know
here in america i mean you're in the
health industry i think it's something
like 42 of americans are considered
obese and it's like 70 something you
know roughly 70 72 percent of americans
are overweight yeah we use the term
called the bmi which is your body mass
index and it takes you well i mean the
40 the 40 like say if you have 40 inch
waist in your man uh if you're five foot
two yeah that's that's a problem yeah
that's a problem but if you're
six ten let's say if you were you know
again
fall back to you know
guys that are athletes i had a guy in my
police academy that was offensive
lineman for the university of oklahoma
yeah he was a big guy but he was
he was a fantastic athlete and he could
tackle people and he could tackle people
and you know and he left tulsa police
department but he's still in law
enforcement to this day working you know
with federal agencies so it can't be
just that as a measurement now one thing
i do 100 believe in
i think there should be mandatory yearly
fitness tests for officers and physicals
uh
you know yes and no
i'd say yes and no i guess that's that's
a hard answer because when i was in
the division that i worked in the
special investigation division we had um
back when meth labs were big when we
were going to
non-stop meth labs you're obviously
around all these chemicals and things
like that so health they want to try to
monitor it so everybody at our division
or everybody was on a meth lab team once
a year you went for a full workup and
i'm talking
the
um you know everything from hearing
eyesight you know lung capacity you know
all these different things they did and
every single year
somebody from my division which only had
53 people
the doctor found something that was
you know abnormal abnormal maybe not
attributed to you know anything to do
with a meth lab
but anything from heartbeats that you
know irregular heartbeat whatever it may
be every year something was found on
somebody
and so
um the physical you know that gets to be
time and cost effective i think for an
agency to have guys do physicals well i
will tell you from my standpoint as a
nurse being a travel nurse i get
background checked i get drug tested i
get a physical
every
[Music]
every time i do a new contract so i have
to have a physical yearly last physical
i got i went to a place and i don't know
what happened but i didn't get any
professional courtesy
i was you were violated they had to draw
labs and they used a uh 18 gauge needle
which is about the size of this pen to
draw my labs which i was like you really
got to go with me with 18 gauge and then
they had to check to see if i had a
hernia i haven't had that done since i
was in
well
high school for a high school physical
you know where you turn your head and
cough i was like you really got to do
this right i'm completely healthy but i
think it's pretty good to have those
physicals just because it kind of shows
you where you are the other thing is too
is that you guys are in a stressful
goddamn job well listen and before we
get there howard i'm going to ask you
because of our camera here
this part right here no i'm just saying
is that part are you not going to be
seeing that
i'm in there it's it kind of spans out
okay that's what i was just making sure
because who who doesn't want to see your
lovely face oh my god i know my beard is
looking righteous it is um by the way i
woke up this morning and right here next
i'm not joking i had one of my beard
hairs that would have been weird
that would have been really weird
i had a black hair that was like a half
inch just sticking out up my face way up
here i don't know how it happened
overnight yeah i know how it's happening
you're getting old i'm getting old um
puberty something else isn't it it is um
[Music]
stress so stressful job yeah i apologize
um i spoke at a conference in baltimore
last year and uh one of the things i
talked about was this profession and
um
i i covered the health and fitness of
police officers during this thing
and i don't remember if i've talked to
you about this or not but
guess what the
age difference is not the the actual age
but the number of years the difference
between a male and a law enforcement
profession
at their life expectancy in somebody in
the civilian world
uh didn't you say like 13 years 22 damn
22 years is the difference and it's
because of those things we're just
talking about
this job is very stressful you're stuck
sitting in your car often a lot of
people have poor eating habits
lack of sleep um shift work all these
type of things they stop you know stop
being physical they're not out doing
something and so you have to make it a
priority because i've seen people in my
own academy when i would teach at the
academy they would go through the police
academy and they get themselves some of
them the best shape they've ever been in
their life and they get out and they get
on the streets and a year later i see
him again and i'm like what happened to
you man you let yourself go you know you
seem three years later and it's even
worse
and it just this profession one you
should be you know take care of yourself
i mean we put money into the pension
20 25 30 35 years then you get to use it
for two you're not staying around
exactly you're not staying around long
enough to to enjoy retirement you're
dying and that's why police officers
have some of the best funding funded
pension systems in the country because
we put money in it and we're not staying
around to use it
like i took three checks and then died
that's it you know and so uh it is very
very important obviously and then it
even goes into
um you know the listen that 22 years
that's a generation that's be that's a
difference of you staying around to be
able to see a grandkid right
you know or something like that but the
uh
you know obviously listen this job
you're going to get in a scuffle or a
fight with somebody at some point you're
going to be dependent upon to pull a
person out of a burning car at some
point you know you never know what's
going to happen
you're going to you know have to fight a
guy for your own gun at some point
you're going to have to you know
whatever it may be there's something out
there have to do
it's physical you're gonna have to jump
out of a car and you know and run to i
don't know a kid drowning in a pond and
you've got to be able to run down this
hill in your gear and go get this kid
whatever it is there's things you're
going to have to be able to physically
do
and you know just like the military
they've got you know physical
requirements it gets broken down by your
age and gender as you get older so the
time gets easier or whatever it is and i
think every department should have that
so i what i hear you saying is yes we
should have physical testing yes we
should have a physical every year for
cops just to help them absolutely that's
called preventative maintenance right
well i mean we can we can do a full
podcast just on this then you're getting
into the the health care costs oh my god
yeah people i mean like i said that's
your expertise but you know the people
that are obese are overweight how much
higher their their medical expenses are
year the impact on the insurance
industry workman's comp just i mean
there's a lot of injuries in the police
job to begin with right um i mean even
things as simple as you're getting out
of your car and you just twist your body
and your back locks up because you're
wearing a gun belt for years and years
sitting in your car in one position in
one position this happens you know i
mean it legit happens everything from
that to you know you punch a guy and
break a hand whatever it may be
but there are you know that that impact
on the police department when that
person's hurt you're pulling them out of
the field and needless to say anytime
you don't feel well you're tired a
little bit it it it affects you mentally
absolutely decision making um your
attitude yeah all of those things so
yeah i kind of agree with that so i'm
with texas on the
figure it out i am terrified to get the
cops a little healthier i did you know
when we were talking 200 guys out of 4
000. i did the percent it's 5
yeah so that's a low number you know
it's five percent that were over that
waistline number especially when you're
talking
70 plus percent of the u.s population is
overweight and 40 something percent are
considered obese so they're obviously
well well well below the national
average of the general public but
they should be able to all pass the
physical i mean pass a physical test and
if so let them do their job absolutely
okay so the next thing that we want to
talk about you and i are no strangers to
planes maybe a traveling nurse you being
a host on a widely popular show
you flew back and forth and back and
forth every weekend and the flying
wasn't so bad but
you know it there's a lot of indignity
you have to put up with going through
the airports going through security um i
got last time i went through i got fully
searched and they touched my junk just
to make sure that i didn't i guess i
went through the scanner and appeared
like a weapon so they had to make sure
it wasn't a weapon a little deuce deuce
a little 22.
hey true story i will
not to you know veer too far from that
i went on a
a
personal vacation recently some other
friends went and a a buddy of mine and
his wife were flying down to meet us and
this buddy of mine is actually a private
pilot on top of that so but he was
flying commercial and uh he
he was meeting us two days after we were
already down where we were at and when
he came through at the airport tulsa
international
uh he had his duffel bag with his pistol
still in it jesus christ loaded loaded
so he goes through he and his wife is he
a police officer he's not a cop no no no
he's a yeah he's a guy that kind of
works in the oil industry here but he's
a private pilot he actually flies the
the company's plane is what he does for
them he needs some protection he does
well it's he had it and he just had his
duffel bag and had he had his gun in it
so he gets stopped there
he ends up um basically they take his
ammunition from him make him run and put
the gun back in the car now it used to
be man you brought a gun through you you
were getting caught and so because i
think it's pretty common you know that
and it's okay
it's oklahoma man and then they're going
to look at intent but
when he did his return flight coming
back to tulsa his tsa privilege had
already been revoked
gone yeah gone and they said it said in
two years uh it would be available for a
review so obviously don't bring a
fucking gun
or a knife or or perfume anything that
slows down the line don't worry
please don't bring your children access
yeah leave your children home or drive
with them don't bring them but we know
during covet that everybody's been
stressed everybody's on edge they're
still doing flights they have more
restrictions they don't serve booze they
make you wear a mask or not you know it
depends on the day every right now we're
in we're in limbo night now you don't
have to right well here's the thing
though i think that when you get on the
plane it's we're all kind of in this
together and you just need to be polite
it sucks it sucks for all of us
everybody absolutely none of us are
special none of us are
entitled to anything that someone else
is entitled unless you're in first class
and you get you get some drinks they
give you alcohol yeah there you go but
i
we can both say that we have all seen
morons on planes absolutely
absolutely you know my biggest pet
peeves on the plane is when you first
get on before you take off and you even
see it in the lounge area at the airport
while you're waiting these fucking
people that have their phone on facetime
and talking on speaker out loud and
people get on the airplane anyway do it
godly drives me crazy yeah the thing
that gets me is the person that has the
obviously this isn't the carry-on sized
bag and they're trying to shove it into
the overhead bin and they just keep
stuffing and stuffing and stuff and just
going to break it
in one case
one case we had a lady did break the
overhead bin and we were delayed while
they had to come and fix it so i was
like that's always a gem you're an
asshole all right the last one for me is
the opposite not when you're taking off
when you stop
and the plane stops and it's on time
there's a method to unloading an
airplane i go you go i go you go from
the front all the way to the back and
these people that try to pal you know
pile through
and if their flight's on time
you know our flight is on time you're
not missing a connecting flight
and luckily
i'm a bigger guy
i just post up and i just stand there i
i have no shame i will just stand right
there and hold you well it's it's like a
common courtesy thing people can be
pretty rude yeah it's like merging onto
the highway you know there's a method to
it don't be a dick you don't stop no and
then wait for somebody to come those are
the words those are well
that's if you're coming on yeah the
people that are worse to me is when i'm
coming on they're in that outside lane
and we'll get the hell out and won't
move over and there's nobody next to
them it's just an empty lane there's
oblivious situational awareness is what
that's called command presence
or command presence to move them over
huh yes all right back to our uh okay so
we had we're gonna talk about crazy
people in airports and the big one that
we can talk about that just happened was
uh or on airplanes was uh mr mike tyson
mr mike tyson boxed someone's head in
yeah he did so i guess he was sitting in
a seat and people are you know i mean
you have this man people are excited to
see you sometimes sometimes yeah it is
uh you know luckily i saw the video with
mike tyson was on a jet blue um flight i
think it was like out of san francisco
maybe or something like that for mike's
life
listen i've never flown jetblue it
doesn't fly here in tulsa you know uh a
a guy that was on the show the director
of his name's john gonzalez i know he
flew jetblue from florida to new york
and listen it must be all right because
john is uh
he is a frugal man but he has done very
well in life he's a multi-emmy
award-winning director
um but he flew jeb blue was very happy
with it but i thought the same thing was
like mike tyson's fine jet blue man what
the fuck well so jet blue is kind of
like their spirit which spirit you you
buy you basically have to buy your
seatbelt once you get you pay for your
ticket no bottom of the barrel yeah
right and then there's kind of southwest
which i mean at least they put a little
bit of the stage presence right and the
stewardesses will tell some jokes and
stuff right or the flight attendant then
you get some peanuts right yeah
absolutely
jet blue is kind of in between now okay
uh
we really will get to these stories but
what's the other one besides spirit
that's kind of down at that level
there's another one uh allegiant
allegiant okay so well allegiance just a
carrier that this does like they just
pick a few like they'll fly out of vegas
there's a legion what we have it comes
in and out of tulsa right oh yeah okay
so i was on a trip down in florida
and i had i think a southwest or america
i had an american or southwest flight
back here we get to the airport it was
for a conference i've got like two and a
half hours three hours till the flight
well i happened to look up and allegiant
had a flight leaving like 40 minutes and
i was like dude i'm gonna jump on and it
was i'm not joking it was like 49 right
so you you pay for the seat then you pay
for your bag then you pay i mean it's
like there's always received but i think
it was like 109. yeah 100 109 bucks i
mean
dead ass serious this was out of florida
the ticket counter that i paid for my
ticket when i go to get on the plane
that was the same person that scanned my
ticket to get on i swear i was worried
about him like flying the plane but it
was the same guy that that paid for the
ticket i guess he closed up shop there
and then goes and lets everybody on the
plane yeah let's see that
so yeah jeffree's like that but mike
tyson
this guy comes up to him he's really
excited on the plane mike's been
drinking a little bit and he's like oh i
can't believe who i'm on he's not you
said mike's been drinking mike hasn't
been drinking i thought he had i thought
he said that he had a few drinks oh i
didn't know that okay that's news to me
i knew the other guy was hammered yeah
based on his appearance but he was just
going at mike he kept going and he was
behind him he got hammered he was behind
he was behind him yeah and he was like
reaching through the seat like hey mike
hey mike
mike had enough turned around and
punched his ass
this is george talking to mike tyson bo
this shit crazy bro mike tyson
[Music]
hey
hey mike mike come on let's go stop back
there's nothing worse man
that blue map flight
boy just got beat up by mike tyson
turned that way
yeah he got fucked up
he's trying to ask for autographs man i
don't know what happened
knew yeah i punched him a handful of
times so the it's a cell phone video
taken from a guy across the aisle and uh
he's even got a little narration himself
like man this dude wild you know he's
wild he's fucking he's taco enticing
he's fucking with mike man you know he
keeps doing it and he takes i guess this
uh
as at least as of the recording of this
podcast the guy's name has not been
released um from my understanding the
guy that got punched in the face
hollyfield no he's this guy still has
his ear he's not vague he doesn't have
his dignity anymore but he does his ear
so my question to you is what do you
think uh mike's going to be a band from
the airlines for life
ah no i don't think he'll get banned for
life so he actually did not even get
arrested at first i didn't even get
arrested so
the the plane was still
there uh you know at the gate and the
door was not closed yet yeah so from my
understanding once the door closes it
becomes a federal thing so that's why
the fbi did not investigate i think
again i think it was san francisco so
that's why san francisco
um pd is investigating it so mike i
guess turns around um you know listen
you poke the bear you know the bear's
gonna bite you sometimes shit it's not
like he doesn't fight you i mean you
know who he is you know what he does 100
percent famous for the hangover remember
and mike tyson just uh you know like a
month ago he was in a comedy club and
some dudes started going off on him did
you see that no was it oh and the guy
pulls out a gun and mike i swear check
it out you need to watch the video the
guy pulls out a gun and mike just stays
there calm and this dude's just like
going crazy talking shit and eventually
he calms down and comes over and gives
tyson a hug
so but but you know it listen man just i
think any person human being
there's personal space around you know
it's like hey man
he took a picture with him you know he
acknowledged him but you got to respect
somebody's personal space obviously is
it criminally wrong to turn around and
start punching and doing the face yeah
yep criminally it is wrong
as a
human being as a man you know if
someone's egging you on to the point
that's why a lot of people do these type
of things they don't get punched in the
face right uh violence is a powerful
motivator pain is pain is a very very we
grew up in the uh days that you got a
spanking
oh boy don't even get me started about
that i got beat my dad figured out that
i finally the only thing that mattered
to me was freedom and started grounding
me and i begged him to beat me yeah i
was like come on dad just bring the bell
back give me as many times as you want
let's get this over with my dad has
hands and i'm not exaggerating i mean my
dad has hands that are like this yeah
you're the run of the family i i really
am i'm you know i'm the small guy my
dad's hands are massive and he had this
big ass ring i don't know if it was a
military ring or like some softball
championship ring because he played
competitive softball and you got a
spanking got your ass banked with that
thing bare-handed and it was miserable
all right two more stories a california
woman was taken off from buffalo going
to chicago and
i don't know how to say it she just
pretty much fucking lost her mind she uh
got in a fight with the flight attendant
uh assaulted the flight attendant and
then did some jason bourne shit she went
to the exit row
okay open the exit door
and once you open the exit door that
little slide oh it just automatically
kicks out yeah yeah
it kicks out she jumps on it slides out
onto the tarmac
this is at the airport yeah it starts
running around the runway
trying to elude the police and of course
you know it probably takes them a little
time to respond
but you know uh tarmacs aren't human
size that's a big track to run on
so she finally gets got and she was uh
um she was charged with disorderly
conduct harassment trespassing and
criminal mischief uh it also said in the
article that she um
the pilot had to return back to the gate
to reinstall the yeah i i i don't know
what that process involves
i i mean your flight's delayed your
flight's fucked
so but this is the thing we're flying
with these people yep which leads you to
believe is
you don't have to be mentally stable to
buy a plane too
correct
you know and
probably more so than that obviously if
it's you know the mental stability issue
right there but we'll go back to the
tyson guy
again i'm watching the video from my
training experience the magic words you
say in a courtroom it appeared the guy
was intoxicated sure that was messing
with them
guys you know a lot of people get to the
airport it doesn't matter the time of
the day they get tanked before they get
on a plane now whether it is because
it's an anxiety thing that they need for
flying i don't know but you can get
pills
you can you can you can crash out and go
to sleep just fine but you know you see
people that get on a plane that normally
don't drink and all of a sudden they're
firing up you know they want drinks all
of a sudden just because they're on a
plane right and there needs to be
um
you know some way
obviously you know a uh a flight
sobriety test before that'd be nice like
a little blow thing at the front because
there are you know flight attendants
because it's not slow enough yet here
sir yeah let's just make it even slower
and here here's the excuse no no that i
had to send some mouthwash but a lot of
these problems i think are alcohol
related obviously hers is a little bit
of different story so you want to do a
slip and slide off of a off of a flight
yeah it was so
this one i
i don't know about you but i'm not sure
that this one is alcohol related okay
which one what we got next so we had a
passenger on southwest who um and you
know southwest is pretty egalitarian
with its seating you can sit wherever
the hell you want
so based on your boarding group right
a b or c and you have to sign up you i
mean you were a big southwest guy i was
yeah so when the show first started i
pretty much flew southwest the whole
time
um
and southwest has
the brand new planes there are a couple
seats that have full leg room right the
older ones
have one so there's three there's three
and an x a row on the um basically if
you're walking down aboarding the plane
on your left and then on the right there
is one seat at the exit there that does
not have a seat in front of it as part
of the exit so i always try to make sure
that you know that 24 hours before
um you you know you're
logging on or whatever
for your boarding pass
i had an account with southwest so it
was basically to the point set up that
it would automatically do that for me
and that was my go-to seat you know to
get
so that i had no nothing in front of me
a couple of times there would you know i
might be passenger number two or three
getting on and a bastard would get there
would be somebody the size of josh
reeser and josh has a small guy
um that would literally get on ahead of
me and go straight to that plane dude it
would piss me off
and
there was even the airline or the flight
attendant i think is the proper term
even uh one of those one time like kind
of just shook their head like wow i
couldn't believe that person did it to
me well this story's about a southwest
flight this guy was in 11f
okay so f would be a window okay on the
right side of the plane right and this
flight was going from uh
seattle washington beautiful place
if you like right uh to phoenix arizona
and the opposite of ring yeah yeah so
this guy antonio
mcgarrity uh was accused of lewd and
indecent or obscene acts while aboard
the three-hour flight i know this story
so during this flight
this uh and he had a lady sitting next
to him i think the center seat was open
he uh he exposed his genitals and
started masturbating right on the flight
not once and not twice not three but
four times in three hours four times did
he finish the three previous times or is
it like just a long process you do it
take a break do it take a break oh shit
i'm sorry there wasn't a middle c it
wasn't taken she was in 11 e right next
to him yeah
right next to him
and he was like i guess his defense was
he goes uh
i think she liked it yeah i thought it
was a little kinky her watching me
which kind of spurred them on
so
you say spurted him
spurned his
[Music]
yeah no i mean who in the hell pulls a
wiener out on a plane and starts working
it a sexual deviant a uh someone who is
you know a sexual deviant in my opinion
someone's intoxicated how does it get to
four times yeah uh how does everybody
else on the road now not not aware of
this paying attention um listen hey
there's the mile high club um i myself
i'm not a fan
not a fan not a member of it you can't
fit the bathrooms
that is very true i can do that headband
yeah when i try to pee in the bathroom
just on on a flight it literally is uh
either a back bend or you it's a it's a
bend forward
hand on the wall in front you know like
when you're really really really
intoxicated and you have to piece you
don't pee all over your toilet it's one
of those just in a standard bathroom on
an airplane but
is is match masturbation does that count
you know for for the mile high club
uh um i guess in this guy's group so
this guy
antonio here uh
the guy with the lewd behavior said that
he uh he knew he was having that he was
doing this and yes he reached orgasm uh
it goes on to say and as i said he
thought it was kind of kinky so at what
point if you're a flight attendant do
you
interrupt this act absolutely do you put
it i mean they've got cuffs put them on
cuffs where was the air marshal on this
flight yeah well
he got a gun out
little baby gun
you know it not just a flight attendant
anybody around there i mean
i'm on a flight you're on a flight and
you see some guy doing that something's
being said i'm gonna punch him in today
you're gonna be mike tyson the guy you
know what i mean something's gonna
happen um obviously a woman next to him
probably pretty damn terrified uh at
least get up go to the bathroom get
he'll pound on the door where the
pilot's at or something so did they
complete the whole pilot did or the
whole flight did this come out like
after they landed or did something came
out it came out
no this they knew they reseeded the
woman during the flight they knew that
this guy was sitting there just spanking
away did they
change their course of their flight to
stop and arrest the guy do you know
anything about that are they complete
just like he did
complete the transaction yes so yeah at
some point you get a as a man if i see
another guy spanking it uh i'll punch
him yeah
in
all seriousness uh we got enough pr
problems without that shit absolutely um
the difference between you know
something of a uh
oh what's the the word i'm looking for
here um you know indecent exposure you
know a sexual um
you know conviction for a sexual act or
something like that there's a difference
between what we call you know we call
open urination um you you you're
standing between a couple cars out there
after the bar at the end of the night
and you're right you're peeing as
opposed to you're turning around and
showing your junk off at an intersection
to a woman in a car next to you it's all
about the intent or this you know it's
this basically being done for sexual
gratification that's the bottom line so
you know you're you you being a mountain
bike rider
you did a mountain bike ride you're
coming back you're going to go into and
have a bite to eat with somebody and
you're changing clothes in the parking
lot and you know i know you wear that
onesie thing and i don't have anything
you don't have anything underneath it
looks like a little wrestling leotard
but you called bibs bibs there you go
you take
someone on that airplane needed a bib
so you uh anyways you change clothes you
know and somebody happens to be in the
parking lot and they see your junk man
that's not a there's no intent on your
part you're you're not going to get in
trouble cop might go hey man dude there
was an intent on this there was a lot of
intent i have several questions this
this man here uh should get a obviously
a conviction and be on a sexual
registration list for the rest of his
life absolutely and at what point how
young was this gentleman that he could
do this four times in three hours
he had never i'll just put it that's
been never in sean larkin's history
right and at 8 000 feet you know you're
a little sleepy anyway i mean the oxygen
you know how many naps were involved in
this dude i wonder you know it's a
pressurized cabin does it change that
the um
the launch
it's not weightless dude it's like it's
not gonna
stick on the vents you know oh okay um
so we've got i don't know four or five
minutes left um
any other news stories you have for us
to cover no i i mean i do but we can't
get into them in this kind of time i
mean i think that all this shit's pretty
it is good obviously
here's what i'm trying to get at if
you're on a plane just be nice it sucks
for all of us big time have your shit
out don't carry a gun through security
or your or your perfume or any liquids
we should know this how long ago was 9
11 uh 2001 i mean so we're talking 21
years now figure out how to get through
security yeah well you know and there's
a comedian if i if i remember correctly
um i think it was lewis black who louis
black lewis black funny fun he has done
he's a very deep voice a very deep voice
funny guy and and he was talking about
the miracle flight basically you are
flying in a metal tube through the air
from one end of the country to the other
in hours something and i'm kind of
paraphrasing what he said and he's kind
of talking about how
a hundred years ago you know 150 years
ago
it was like a generational thing to
cross the country like people have died
trying to get from one end to the
country it's a great wrath
literally you know i mean that you know
getting through the mountains and that
type of stuff and it's like
quit bitching if your flight's delayed
listen it sucks you're right i want to
get home you know i want to get to that
destination there's no sense of bitchin
but don't don't don't yeah don't don't
attack uh you know verbally of course
physically the flight attendants or a
pilot they all are getting
they want to get to where they want to
get to also you know and it's just it's
pretty fucked up man and just saw a deal
a lot of these people that have been
kicked off of planes um during the covet
stuff whether it was the mask policy
they disagreed with or whatever it was
some of these airline companies now that
the mass deal is changing are evaluating
letting these people back on and that
right there shows you the power of money
right that they want money you know they
don't want to lose someone from their
airline to another airline i think it's
bullshit i think if you're on a flight
and you've whether it's physically
attacked another passenger you
physically attack the flight attendant
or you delay this
exactly you should who gives a shit dude
you should just drive by a greyhound bus
ticket yeah um lastly
johnny depp stuff's going on um i know
that is a huge huge thing a lot of
people are paying attention to it
all i got to say is wow yeah that's a
that's a fucked up relationship
oh shut up we've all been in this well
not
that
using cocaine throwing bottles of wine
secretly recording conversations and
videos yeah that's one and over anybody
listening out there you were remotely in
a relationship like that get the fuck
out just just end it there's no sense
why would you stay in there nobody
should be a you know that there's
allegations of physical abuse from both
sides don't be a punching bag in a
domestic situation to somebody you don't
need to stay around and be in that and
that's not even any fun why why is that
relationship fun well you know the
problem johnny depp can't get any women
yeah women women are not attracted
they're not attractive he's not cool
doesn't have any money he's not unique
he can wear scarves dude and i make up
and and pulls off hot chicks man how's
that happen him and lenny kravitz man
yep
lenny's a cool dude
lenny kravitz is a cool dude yeah he
doesn't and i love all the pirates of
the caribbean movies man i like john
he's not going to be in any more of them
though
no all right lastly
crime con las vegas nevada yeah it's
coming up next yeah it's going to be the
weekend of uh we'll be there on
friday april 29th saturday april 30th
and sunday
april 31st april 31st didn't know how
many days in the month april you're
going to may have i was so we will
howard and i will be out there uh jason
will be there with us as well we are
going to be set up at crime con
we'll have a booth out there on podcast
row we are doing a bunch of podcasts
we'll be doing some of them live come
out say hi love to see everybody for
those of you that don't know crime con
is uh it's a big it's a convention for
anybody that's involved that like likes
the crime genre there are
serial killers murder podcasts well
there's not phil there's nothing
predator yeah
there's not actual
serial killers there
yes there are there well
if you're a fucking serial killer you're
going to cry oh god and you're walking
and just taking in the loving it that
you haven't been caught you know they
are but yeah in in vegas there it's got
everything from uh like i said podcast
row tons of different podcasts that
cover crime true crime things like that
there are authors that have covered true
crime i don't know if there's fictional
authors or not then they've got uh just
as howard was saying everything from
different tv shows
huge huge huge genre everybody loves it
come out there say hi to us cocktails
and cocktails yeah we'll have uh we'll
have some drinks there we'll pour you a
little bit boom all right that's kind of
fun that's a good one see you guys next
time